saying goodbye to a father grandfather
and husband the family of eric
echevarria held a vigil to honor his
life
after he was killed in a car crash
madison kimbrough shows us how they paid
tribute from the memorial site
you know if you're going gonna drink or
get high whatever you're gonna do do it
in your house like don't
drive he took a a dad from my 14 year
old son he took my husband my
my best friend my life partner my my
everything i don't even know what i'm
gonna do without him
a visual was held for 52 year old eric
echeverria
who died last week after being hit by a
teen driver
that teen 19 year old zeon collins is
being accused of driving under the
influence
and is facing several other charges my
family is hurting
they're in pain they feel that justice
hasn't been served
and i know it's too soon to speak but
we're hoping that
something does happen tonight friends
and family came out to honor eric's life
flowers balloons and pictures were all
set up
along with music playing in the
background family members and friends
spoke briefly before participating in a
two-minute moment of silence you know it
has taken a little bit
for it to sink in you know i'm still
denial still in shock that
that he's gone so we're just
setting everything up making the
arrangements for you know for our
service
echeveria was described as a happy man
always smiling joking around with a
heart of gold
he was originally from new york but
spent the last 23 years here in las
vegas
he was an army vet and worked as a
custodian for the clark county school
district
for 18 years madison kimbrough 8 news
now